Africa is perhaps the continent
that needs least convincing
about the clean energy opportunity
for health, livelihoods and economy.
As the fastest-growing, yet
least-electrified continent on the globe
most in need of power systems
that can help fortify
against the onslaught of climate shocks
and with both abundant fossil
and renewable energy
resources to build them,
Africa's energy transitions
and how to dissuade
the use of fossil fuels
have become an intense
international debate.
But what the debates often miss
is that Africa is not a single story.
As an energy systems modeler,
I can tell you that though
the baseline is low,
where they do have power,
many Sub-Saharan African countries
already rely on low-carbon resources.
Kenya, where I live,
generates 90 percent
of its power from renewables
like geothermal and hydropower.
Even in West Africa,
where renewable shares tend to be lower,
countries like Ghana generate
over a third of their power
from renewable energy resources.
And countries like Namibia
are at the forefront of innovation
on clean fuels like green hydrogen.
Couple all of that with housing
one of the world's largest carbon sinks,
the Congo Basin,
and Sub-Saharan Africa
is consistently recognized
as pulling more than its fair share
of the global decarbonization effort.
So unlike the deep emissions reductions,
and urgent pivot away from fossil fuels
we need to see from heavy emitters,
Sub-Saharan Africa and energy transitions
are more a question of how
to quickly ramp up generation
and distribution capacities
in ways that are affordable,
accessible, resilient,
while staying the course
of climate compatibility.
So if the need is urgent
and if the resources are bountiful,
then why are we still so far away
from this clean energy future for Africa?
I've led the design and deployment
of energy projects here myself.
And I found and what I've learned
is that though the world
loves to remind Africa
about its vast clean energy potential,
the financial flows
to deliver that potential
remain troublingly scarce.
Projects and businesses incur a number
of hidden compounding costs and premiums.
Like the risk perception premium.
Or the “paying back your US dollar loan
in a constantly depreciating
local currency” premium.
Or the “expected to deliver
conventionally high rates of return
while raising your revenues from customers
that earn less than a dollar
a day” premium.
So international finance markets
are not appetized
and financial flows here remain a trickle
despite a pipeline of ready projects.
Effectively, this prioritizes
risk to capital
over risk to human life.
In fact, though, 17 percent
of the global population
and almost 90 percent of those
still without access to basic energy,
today, Africa accounts
for a mere two percent
of global clean energy finance.
These realities of local enterprise
rarely make it into the models
or the debates,
leaving us with a skewed perception
of what transition really takes
or why progress might seem so slow.
From this perspective,
we can see a key missing ingredient:
International cooperation
to deliver the finance flows
that Africa sorely needs
because there’s so much potential
waiting right at the cusp.
If local enterprise had access
to long-term, low-cost financing,
like their counterparts
in other regions of the world
can simply take for granted,
then Africa's clean energy future
would build itself.
We know this because African communities,
by their actions,
show us the kinds of futures
that they want.
As our cushioned conferences
wax on year after year,
my friend Jeffrey runs a solar company
that targets commercial
and industrial customers,
helping to kick-start what has become
the fastest growing wave
of solar across the continent.
And also demonstrating
that African businesses
see value in being powered by renewables.
My neighborhood buddy, Samir,
runs a solar irrigation company.
It's estimated that about 95 percent
of farmers in Africa
still rely entirely
on increasingly erratic rains.
So this is a game changer
for food security.
My former student, Phoebe,
she now designs fuel-efficient cook stoves
that reach into thousands of homes
from Zambia to Mozambique,
providing sustainable alternatives
to what is actually the largest
energy use on the continent,
household cooking.
And at the World Resources Institute,
we support dozens of young Rwandan,
Ugandan and Kenyan
electric mobility start-ups
that are revolutionizing
the face of transit in East Africa.
These are real people,
real stories, real families
representing a real
wave of local enterprise,
successfully serving communities across
an entire spectrum of energy needs.
These are real salaries,
real rents, real mortgages,
real savings being put
on the line every day.
Is that not the utmost confidence
in Africa's clean energy
business potential?
Imagine how fast we could go
and how far we could move
if they had a level playing field
instead of yet more obstacles to climb.
And if they can be invested,
then what excuse remains for those
with the means and the responsibility?
Africa is speaking.
But it's not one story.
It's not even 54 stories.
It's the stories of thousands
of communities
mobilizing the features they want
and inviting the world's
partnership in it.
Partnership.
Not charity, not a victim song,
but fairness and cooperation.
Ambitious, time-bound commitments
to deliver long-term,
low cost financing at scale
from countries, banks
and development finance institutions.
Two, increased concessional financing,
not reclassified financing,
that doesn’t just target
the easily profitable projects,
but that is leveraged to drive global
capital to least-electrified communities.
And three.
Programs that expand
the access to that finance
and initiatives that bolster
local supply chains,
generating value, revenues,
employment and skills at home.
These are the solutions
that the international community
must make an urgent priority,
even as African countries
do their own homework
to improve the local business environment.
And this, delivering accessible,
clean energy financing at scale
will be a far more productive show
of partnership and trust
than debating what countries should do
with their available resources.
Climate justice
is heavy emitters cooperating
to realize clean energy futures
for those countries
that have been denied,
locked out of their fair share
of a global carbon budget.
So today, let's cut past the talk
and focus on unleashing the avalanche
of a clean-energy future
that Africa is ready to deliver.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)